[Applause]
for the first time in 30 years Dock
Workers here are on strike
[Applause]
what do we want for the next eight days
eighty percent of the workforce at the
UK's largest container Port will be
absent overpay it's everyday living it's
if we don't catch up now when do we
catch up
we we need to make the stand now
whatever the hell this ends this this
dispute whatever we gain we'll be going
on utility bills and more so no one's
coming out any winner in this these
workers say a seven percent pay rise
plus 500 pounds isn't enough for a
company making multi-million pounds in
profit the port says workers are being
used as pawns disputed by the union it's
nothing to do with the national strategy
or anything like that it's Sammy which
has happened here at a local level and
it reflects what's happening elsewhere
because people all over the country I
think are feeling the same way that's
why it appears to be you know perhaps it
appears to be coordinated because people
everywhere are feeling the same way and
and coming to the same conclusion enough
is enough we are not going to take this
anymore with a slowing economy and
recession forecast Paul Davey speaking
for the port says they believe the
payoff is fair we pay 43 000 pounds a
year each average that's 40 percent more
than the national average and I think
that is a fair reward for them you know
these are not all all easy jobs but then
there's a lot of jobs that aren't easy
that are on minimum wage absolutely we
agree they deserve a fair day's pay for
a fair day's work and I think that's
what we give them but an eight-day
strike is going to hit the supply chain
1900 Workers are striking here which is
having a direct impact on the port there
which is on the front line of UK trade
and right now inside it's empty no
movement no deliveries in or out
and that means businesses like this
Adam's local haulage firm are losing out
it's damning I've been trying to uh do
the cost and I think about 60 maybe 70
000 pounds it will cost me this week
and and why is having such an impact on
you
um because we heavily involved with
feelings so poor it's it's a heavy
percentage of all the business that we
do and if we can't collect our
containers we can't deliver for our
customers and we can't earn money and
it's going to be a very tough time
it's a familiar sight and as the cost of
living crisis continues to squeeze it's
here to stay Adele Robinson Sky News
felixstowe